effectively I'm going to keep this very
quick based on you've had meetings all
day so this is the annual report that we
provide to counsel from the carboy food
first
as as usual I always make at least one
mistake in my report and hopefully
anybody that's read the report has found
that have you found it on page three it
talks about how many visitors visitors
we get to the food virus via Google and
it's actually ten thousand so every
month we get ten thousand visits on
Google effectively if you were to look
at the food forest in relation to the
amount of visitors that we get not only
online but also physically through the
food forest we get them from all over
the world just as you've seen in the
report we get them from Japan in one day
I had six international visitors from
all over the world it was just
extraordinary the thing is that we've
been going for three years now over two
thousand trees and plants have been
donated by the local residents and it
just goes to show as to how the
community have become involved in this
project in how they want to become more
involved in the project the issue that
we have currently at the moment is that
we still do not have an updated license
to occupy we're still waiting for a
response to that we would like to see at
some stage a building on-site and
potentially a toilet as well ideally at
will it follows on in terms of the food
forest report it follows also on with
regard to Tessa's presentation later on
in your meeting and regards to food
secure communities and I believe that
the food forest is going to be an
element that the government would love
to see more of and let us having more
and more food forests around all of New
Zealand and potentially all around the
way maquette of you as well it's about
it from me thank you if there's any
questions
[Music]
thank you very much Brandon it's been
able to brilliant to see the work that's
been done there and when you talk about
like a toilet facility have you
investigated things like composting
toilets that side of things as well or
were you thinking you wanted it
connected into their reticulation
thinking that was one of the questions I
would I had asked by one of the trustees
today so previously the food forest was
on site there was nine previous
residential sections on that one site so
potentially there may be existing so
running past either on castle beyond
Cass so potentially there but we've seen
in other places composting toilet
alternatives which could potentially
work on that site we're not looking in
terms of a building we're not wanting a
large building we're wanting effectively
a building that could house small
education programs like we had the first
school come back to us today that was
carpooling north and like we've got
University of Canterbury coming tomorrow
so it's like when it's wet we would like
to have the opportunity that we could
talk about the food forest and
potentially be undercover at the same
time but to answer your question
both composting and or reticular
connecting into the existing sewer
system would be ideal renewing the lease
yes we're working on that and I
apologize for the delay that has gone to
property and we are chasing that up the
matter of the toilets of all
descriptions as being as being discussed
by staff we'll get back to you within
that within the month whether it was a
decision on suitability and availability
and we were going with it so both those
matters are are under control
I was going to ask a question regarding
the pavilion all the buildings that are
going to be built for the for the yeah
how far away are they from the yeah
thank you because I just thinking that
thank you I just wondered where we were
getting to with the toilets having
discovered the cost of a toilet last
evening at the highway 280 we Community
Board you know 350 thousand or something
if you want a new toilet scene it's
pretty expensive
assuming well effort went down the path
it would be I think that being a
charitable trust we have the opportunity
to go out to the community and actually
fundraise a lot of this in actually
funded ourselves so yeah we potentially
would would do all that ourselves so
that would be including a toilet and
it's more educational facility
I simply just wind up say Brent love
your work keep up the awesome awesome
work good see
good afternoon the public refuse burdens
policy has been around for probably
about three years and it has gone round
many iterations of policy starting out
with a simple review of the original
policy and then considering whether it
should be built into the public spaces
policy as well it was put on the back
burner while it was discussed and then
it came back round last year saying that
management team suggested that perhaps
we look at incorporating recycling and
have another look at the charitable
burns that were also seen to be a bit of
an eyesore on the entrance to our town
and and some intersections so we did
that we looked again at the policy and
decided that after much consideration
that we go back to first principles go
back to what it was originally and it's
about public rubbish burns outside shops
in new areas as well as existing areas
and as part of the review I went through
every service request that mentioned a
rubbish burn for the last three years
and analysed whether this policy was
actually going to assist us in making
decisions around those service requests
and discovered that on the whole yes it
did the question of public recycling has
a much wider question that in discussion
with kitty and who team is more about
how do we manage it how do we get this
public recycling done without
contamination and of course that's quite
a vexatious issue and in a much wider
issue than this somewhat more simple
policy so I give you the policy today
and would be happy to answer any
questions that you've got regarding the
review and our recommendation that this
policy is adopted at this stage
then the policy drives what this council
does and where it spends its money
why wouldn't we consult on something
that's had a high interest in his head
many public submissions through that in
your plan for years why wouldn't we do
some sort of community consultation on
the community views this is not sort the
policies intended to guide us on where
we put our rubbish bins and things like
there in reviewing all the service
requests and I can't actually recall in
our customer satisfaction survey and
things like that that the a lot of it's
about your why when we got recycling and
things like that but this policy is
actually about where we put a rubbish
bin and who pays for it basically and we
decided that it's these are council
policies to guide our work a full green
space in the the narrower vision of
where we put a rubbish bin rather than
that broader community vision of the
service we're providing with waste
generally and there's going to be
obviously some more work done with that
Minh the sustainability strategy that
next tranche if that comes through I
think it's stage three talks to the
community about that wider rubbish
situation yes
the recycling itself in terms of just
talking through that one of the things
that we need to do is actually establish
how operationally they would work public
recycling bins to avoid them going to
landfill there's actually an
intervention that's required there
around contamination so we need to have
a look at how that would actually work
because there's more of an operational
outcome than a pure policy decision to
say that this is where we would put them
there's quite a few other things that
we'd need to consider there but they bit
to my question community views guiding
the council there's not even the
community boards have not even had a
chance to make any comment on this
policy is that correct no no they
haven't I think with the review that the
plan was that the the draft was brought
to you that is still a draft policy and
the committee had the opportunity to
make any comments about the draft policy
and if obviously if you want us to go
out for public consultation then we'll
we'll look at that we like lilius if we
could absolutely go to the community and
consult with the community boards and it
didn't have a look at this if we were
going to look to do broader recycling in
our public areas and that's something
which is a level of services probably
best discussed as part of a long-term
plan and or through the sustainability
policy which I believe stage four is
going to address a lot more of that
community-based sustainability
initiatives in so we could we could do
both we can take this as a more
operational policy which is looking at
where we put out if use Benzi at the
moment and who pays for those to the
community boards for their consideration
but then we could also look at our
levels of service and time for the long
term plan and much we could consult Ron
noting that we have done this before as
part of previous long-term plans and
whydid information through the council
in terms of both the capital costs of
putting in the recycling burns but then
which was reasonably high but more the
operational cost of double was basically
for all other bins that we have put in
recycling bins so we're happy to to do
that again and recast dead and then
consoled them that is part of the
long-term plan if it was to do is the
sticking point with regards to having
recycling bins and in parks and whatnot
the fact that the recyclables need to be
washed out and they never can be if
you're just throwing something away
because that does make it quite
challenging and difficult to actually
include those in it's it's disappointing
to see that that public recycling goes
to the tip but whenever you look at it
the challenge is that you know you'd
have to go through enhance or and wash
out every single item before it went
anywhere that does make it difficult so
unless we could couple them with a wash
station which is probably never going to
happen I can understand where your
challenges are there
policy discussions that are recycling as
we go into the thank you I agree that
this is this public if you've been
policy is correct
moving forward we will seriously look at
recycling and but just at the present
time in with the covert nineteen and the
extra costs associated with I think we
just need to take a little breather and
antagonistic back on and do this as and
when we can afford to do so look I'm
comfortable with the recommendation I'd
have been happy for it to have gone to
the board's for to hear their opinion
maybe they will is a consequence of the
if they wish to but I would have been
pretty happy for that but I'm not going
to die on the Dutch I really think it
achieves the same thing as the Brian but
for dear I've hidden approached by woody
in school and I'm going to see students
on Friday they would like to see dog
litter burns and their parka so it's
hardly a particular policy that they've
got so I'm going to see the Imam Friday
about your ideas around there and my
suggestion would be to them that will to
work with them through the consultation
process through the LTP if it's how they
want to do that so these these students
are in a stage where they an age where
they would be able to progress that
through next year so they that may well
be a submission that comes to us on
there but the meter around recycling
bins I note the comments that have been
cedar I get a lot of requests from
people who would like to see an
additional level of service but I
appreciate what Cassidy mentioned before
that comes with a cost
and they'd space to that I and I think
thanks Lenny for your work on this and
supports you have any comments and
welcome seeing what they are and look
forward to hearing what woody in school
have to say on on the space where I see
them on Friday being on council means
you have to represent the people that
are out there that you're talking to and
the people in my demographic no longer
see it acceptable to put recycling in a
rubbish bin other councils around the
country have gotten joint burn
initiatives and we've been talking about
this for years and years and why
McCready is actually legging behind
other areas so I'm a bit concerned I
know there is a cost to recycling I'm
full aware of that but what is the cost
of not recycling what is the cost of
filling up our landfills what is the
cost to our future generations so we
have to consider that covered has come
in and it may reassess all our
priorities I understand that but this is
actually really important this is a
into issue it's a policy and if we have
a policy all our operations are guided
by their policy so I think it's really
important that the community boards
should appear to say in this I think
it's really important that we should
test to see where their appetite errs as
to what they're prepared to spend losses
what they're prepared to throw away so I
actually on this one you know there are
other councils doing this so how do they
do it do they have people after school
claiming out the recycling and sorting
it we don't know because we haven't got
that information but it's definitely
worth investigating that would actually
create jobs who knows I understand in a
covert environment it's going to be
difficult to add cost however I'll ask
you again what is the cost of not by
building waste in our current
environment
to terrify the fun if I may know nothing
in this report prevents what counselor
boner is irrigated so if the community
wants there if they demographic wants
that the net demographic can come here
and tell us through the LTP process
I think you mr. chair
so this is I guess a long time coming
the one that carry public arts trust
there's a lot of background in there I
won't go through the full background and
I'll take that background as read this
report is looking to appoint five people
and a single councillor to be on the
wire mercury public arts trust
councillor windy duty and councillor
Robbie Brian and myself held interviews
after a experience and exhibitions of
interest process and we had some some
really good high-caliber people from our
community who really saw the value and
the why McCree public public arts trust
wants to be a part of that to progress
public art in our district we were very
impressed with those that put their
hands up and unfortunately there were
some which we didn't feel could were up
to the standard of others and therefore
we've recommended the five that are on
here now that the change which has been
identified in the report to the actual
trust deed is the reduction a number of
council councillor appointees to the
group it was identified originally as
two and a discussion between councillor
duty and councillor Brian and myself it
was recommended that we reduced that to
one the reasons identified in the report
and specifically around reducing the
elected member influence on public art
it's meant to be an independent and
group of people who are making
independent decisions on art in public
places and then also giving the trust
the opportunity to employ a further
member in the future if they wish to do
so being that we're recommending five
and they are only allowed seven with one
councillor that would mean sex and they
would have the ability to bring someone
else on in the future if they saw fit
I'm happy to take any questions on page
47 second point
down I think there may be a typo it sees
a further member over time can employ up
to five thank you I belong already to
the Waimakariri what are we call a
collection that collection trust and
I've checked with staff make sure there
wasn't a conflict of interest and
they've agreed there isn't and there's
sort of an overlap and one will feed off
the other Oh a little bit so particular
interests of mine so I'm pretty happy
accepting that position
you
if I'm comfortable with the
recommendation that's either all the
individuals said the listed the cave I
know a number of them Jackie Wilson and
Nicole they and readeth of course not
quite a weird doll for you but but all
of them bring real skills in the space
and knowledge and patient about so it's
well overdue this trust in healing the
sister established it's a number of
proposals that have been waiting the
establishment of this to proceed someone
I know is prepared once to put a mural
and combo line for instance so AG
require this body in which to consider
the appropriateness of this so I know
counselor duties had a lot to do with
the original establishment of this and
well done to here and counts the brine
for the week as they've gone through
it's great to see that there's such an
interest around among colleagues for the
Arts the Arts is something that's really
important and that's the strict but I do
know yes the Blakey here's a lot of
interest in there and I think it's a
good dovetailing with as week with the
art collection trust so that's why I was
prepared to support just very quickly
just to recognize sir if it's a mr.
Brean and early tire as well putting
that this was a comprehensive process to
get here today yes I I would just like
to concur with it Riya preciate their
work that Chris and Robbie and myself
Wheaton the work we did to go through
and check these grits is quite a big big
selection and very high caliber and to
get down to this group that we've
appointed that's it's a really good
starting point for our why may carry
Public Arts trust trust Jesus it's
fabulous and absolutely thrilled with
with what else what it's doing what it
will be doing
and I've got one or not so that
desperately needs to be look at just
last month a year ago if we would like
to this was gifted they put it in to do
anything I'm thinking I'm just just
wanted to also commend this report and I
just want to take my hat off to the
caliber of the people that have come
forward and you can see their passion
and the applications that they put
through and I mean we're so fortunate to
have people with so much ability and
background in in the arts that are
coming forward to do this for our
district I didn't put my hand up for
this because I just don't feel worthy
looking at such an amazing field and I
know that there are others that have a
much stronger background in that area
but um I think this is this is going to
go on to do great things and yes thank
you for all the work that's gone in
behind it
maybe grant wants to come to the table
and we're sort of Tim might be better to
have grown there I can start presenting
the report there might be some questions
grant can answer it's been a bit of a
joint process between grant and Ida to
get to this stage while my name's on the
report it doesn't necessarily mean I was
responsible for fully writing it so the
North Canterbury minibus trust I don't
think I need to go into the details
around what they do I think councillors
are aware of what North Canterbury mini
bus trust does in their importance for
our community we have been they came to
us a number of years ago asking for a
location to be able to build a cover for
the various vehicles and then also a
little small space for to be able to
meet we at the moment you'll know that
they're on Blake Street and the attend
you there is not likely to be long term
based on the potential for development
of this site in the future we have been
through a long process it's always very
difficult to try and find suitable land
for people land also always has an
opportunity cost involved in putting
someone or something on that land this
reserves act to consider there's the
needs and months of the minibus trust
themselves and so the best way we
thought to do that was to create a
matrix of weighted matrix and you'll see
the weighted matrix attached and the
results of that weighted matrix as a
winner which is this small piece of land
211 Marsh Road which is next to the
water unit we've had there were a number
of pieces of land which were identified
through both the which made the matrix
and then some which we put on the matrix
but didn't actually take through to the
report is we're getting fully evaluated
because they had reasons why they
basically couldn't go any further
and so those are identified in the
matrix as well the North Carolinian
gave us the requirements for different
pieces of land and I happy with the size
of this piece of land in the location of
this piece of land
right down to the fact that they guess
their vehicles at BP and this is a
closer to BP than some of the other
pieces of land so it was quite detailed
their requirements and what they wanted
they are requesting a 20-year lease
that's going to give them the longevity
they need to be able to invest the sort
of money they want to invest to actually
get the facilities they want to get we
think this is the best outcome and that
we've been able to achieve throughout
this process I'm happy to take any
questions thanks grant and Chris for the
report just on the location at Marsh
Road is there any issues with this
particular site with potential future
bypass of the town renderer so we spoke
to the roading Department about that and
they provided us some maps which
identified there this piece of land is
slightly to the south of where the
bypass would go through and it would
leave that piece of land alone
essentially and the bypass road is
relatively wide in terms of the land
that they would need for their bypass
identified on the map so we consulted
with Joe and McBride around that and
they were happy that this location would
be suitable and for the 20-year lease to
just say
you to ground and Chris for the work
that's been done this has been over a
number of years I've certainly been
involved and some of the questions that
have come by myself over the years
working with Greg right and and others
they've been trying to find a solution
of a lean site war they've period of
time and it's needed because they've
Eanes
in vehicles are deteriorating sitting
outside they're going to have a lot of
work to do to to fundraise to get the
building actually built but I know that
they're looking to partner with the
likes of rotary for instance which is
another organization it's requiring
storage for books to for the book sale
that they do annually because location
they're presently goddess is got some
challenges so I think this is a really
good outcome at a fantastic organization
the many best trust that there's a lot
to help vulnerable people in our
community get to appointments so I can
what's ok is mover I'm hippie to
acquiesce to their so to lease rather
than a license to occupy it and I'm
comfortable with the term that's
mentioned as well a for any organization
that's looking for funding if they don't
give it to him of their sort that
they're going to find it difficult to
achieve funding so in inter to to build
on sort of a really good outcome think
you should the staff for the work that
they've done to get and so for mine
they're very commendable I can think you
guys any other speakers recommendation
the met metals aquatic
thank you so the purpose of this report
is to update the community and
Recreation Committee on our activities
in year to date progress as I'm sure you
appreciate covert 19 had a significant
impact across our customers staff and
facilities this report which I'll take
is read highlight season pets but also
identifies the opportunities that the
situation created and both to complete
maintenance works in for aquatic staff
to support the council and its
vulnerable community members further it
touches on the financial impacts of this
unprecedented event we had promising
numbers in our learn to swim level 2
program which started in recently and
currently taking bookings for levels
term three full return to learn to swim
aerobics started back this week with a
class this morning here in 30
participants which is right up there
with our busiest days so it's good to
see us back at normal levels and finally
is approved in the new plan July 1 will
see a small fees and charges increase
coming into a feet we do appreciate that
the due to the current economic
environment
this changes unlikely to be well
received so we continue to work with
councils communication engagement team
to can communicate the reasons for this
change and continue to ensure that
there's an equilateral balance between
user pays in rates funding I am happy to
take any questions
much appreciated
council any other questions for me I
wandered mate on page 74 the Dudley Park
figures appear to be down more than a
higher point Paul would there be any
reason for the just looking at a
proportion in attendance east they table
you've got under 4.1 so I'm sorry I
don't follow that the numbers are
actually higher am i sorry I was reading
it under carpel way the May 20 numbers
were 621 compared with 7,000 on the
previous year so there was data
reduction of about 12 12 times where
Dudley Park your May 19 figure with
17,000 and they've dropped right back to
1044 which seem to me to be a higher
drop sorry I follow now that's because
of the loon to swim fee essentially we
have a lot more loon to swim through a
Dudley Park up with it is a bigger
facility as you know so we have the
greater capacity to get more people
through those programs and schools
programs and all of those sorts of
activities so of course when they drop
away it's a great roommate as well
great a great report overall I just had
a question on 6.1 you've got
depreciation as being greater
year-to-date actual then budgeted how is
it that the depreciation is more over
lockdown than forecast I don't believe
it's more over lockdown than forecast
and I keep that one with finance because
I had the same question in six-point 1.5
as it sees the variation and
depreciation results from a valuation of
land and buildings which occurred after
the annual plan budget was finalized
which is the word and they gave me so no
no that's right not - yeah thank you
very much for your report is very good
I'm sorry I haven't as yet managed to
get into your establishment
but I will say the the comments coming
back that now that that pull is open
that's not just overwhelming that the
adults that were desperately wanting to
start to do the the laps and also the
ones that doing the aerobics though
actually meet a group of them by sheer
accident at just across over and Co
having copies afterwards and they were
absolutely just so thrilled to be part
of it again so thank you just concur
with the comments of Cassidy and also
council Becky at the start just the way
in which your staff have certainly been
happy to be redeployed at various
locations over somewhere even if you're
in the council building to me down to
the transfer station and they were staff
down near the reaching people and the
recycling to the birria to the
supermarket's they've done a fantastic
job and you know clearly being very
understanding through a difficult period
of time really pleased that the
maintenance has been undertaken through
that period and I'm pleased that the
manager's office and
killer as has been named in their just
office when we meet for the tour around
I was quite surprised the conditions
that you were working under but it's
given the chance for a bit of a spruce
up and which was which was needed so
it's an ideal opportunity look thank you
for what you've been doing in all your
staff I'm pleased that we're up and
running again in the people can use our
facilities but very good report and look
forward to further reports of progress
through the year thanks man
Matt I just wanted to take the
opportunity to say that I really commend
you and your staff and thank you for
going the extra mile and going out and
helping our community whenever you
couldn't be in that pool and I really
also would like to tip my hat for the
fact that you guys have managed to make
lemonade out of those lemons that you're
handed and managed to squeeze in some
some maintenance and and some
renovations of a certain office and you
know I just think that was an excellent
use of time and yeah well done so thank
you
like no because I've got a
around for a while you met very much
appreciate the level of effort that you
and your staff have put on like the
other ones I've seen and we really would
like let me past on thank you and I
can't wait to see your new office
kyouda koto it's nice to be back
it's my report is to provide you all
community and Recreation Committee with
an update on the usage and statistics of
our district library services
it was a large report apologies for this
I'll take it as large you read and if we
have time can I draw your attention to
just a couple of points thanks so given
so much of the report was dominated by
covert I thought I'd draw your attention
to 4.2 stories not statistics capturing
stories feedback form and on dotted
around the desks you'll have a piece of
paper with a series of kids on it and
that's the form that I'm referring to so
it seems like a long time ago when I
last reported to you in February and we
had just finished our first ever full
staff Hui a true attorney oh boy
one of the outcomes from that meeting
it's 4.2.2 they kept doing stories for
now traditionally library kpi's and
traditional quantitative data gathering
supply you with statistics that count
measure and record library transactions
and KPIs
the number of loans number of visitors
in the number of website hurts but the
qualitative data and the stories that
these forms will gather and what stories
they'll tell will give the missing but
that will give you the data give you the
stories that the data will miss and
they're going to encourage us as
libraries team the whole team to think
about and report on the who the why in
the what I'll refer you refer you to
four point two point five the story of a
young man and regular user error Overton
F Akaya boy who shared that the library
had been essential getting his small
business off the ground and how super
grateful he was he was printing off his
end of job summary and receipt for his
first construction job and posters small
posters to advertise his business now
quantitative data ring data-gathering he
would have been one transaction on a
door count one visitor in potentially
one a P and K one of the free computer
users now we were able to tell his story
and share the value that the space and
the services and the staff have made to
him in the community and by involving
our customer facing staff and
recognizing and then capturing the
community stories of how and why they
use the library we'll be able to report
on the difference that our libraries our
district library services are making
while still continuing to report on the
traditional KPIs and then I'd like to
refer you to four point nine alert level
two and libraries reopen for business no
report would be complete without covert
piece so the shift to alert level two on
may the 14th saw 30 of the 32 permanent
library staff back on site at one of the
libraries we had two exceptions to age
and compromised immune systems and they
were working from home and preparation
for level 2 compliance which was
rigorous and Quarantine eing returning
processing and shelving the nearly 7,000
books that came through the slot in four
days my team were flat out some of them
work through the weekends and we opened
on Monday the 18th and then and those
subsequent four days we saw a 37%
increase in loans close to seven and a
half thousand compared with the same
period last year in unsurprisingly 70%
increase in the number of returned items
we had close to 10,000 books coming
through the door or through the return
slot in four days the four point nine
point six are referred to the library
and information sector collaboration
through zoom through the Library
Association lian zone in public
libraries New Zealand I'd like to
recognize that why market early
libraries was
of a very small handful of libraries
offering my book bag and click and
Collect
at a lutely of all three in there our
process that was rigorously checked by
Waimakariri health and safety pushed up
to the CD HB pushed up to the chief
medical officer that proposal has been
shared with over a dozen councils for
release as an alert level to service in
some have written asking for permission
to copy it as a business-as-usual
service italy at no alert level the
libraries team focused and locked down
and once the library is opened was of
being of service in meeting the needs
and expectations of the community my
team offered a hundred and 423 virtual
programs from their own homes curated
500 bags did home deliveries and their
own car direct to your device ebook
resource services hosted book bubble
book groups with an age range from 3 to
92 plus all the behind scenes mentioned
in the report and when our doors opened
on May the 18th
not one person booked or pushed back on
the challenge of our commitment to open
with close to full business as usual
every services when other councils
around New Zealand we're not opening
library doors to the community until a
lutely ever won or opened with click and
Collect only and no public internet no
public Wi-Fi newspapers magazines in
some case seats I wanted to draw your
attention to the dedication kia empathy
and kindness that the libraries team
showed our district virtually an in
person in a continuing to docents
lockdown happy to take any questions
thank you very much I'm sure the
committee will join me in questions
anyone
pretty self-explanatory give yourself a
big pat on the back I think you must
Paul or I'd like to congratulate you and
your team for what you've done over the
lockdown period in particular I'm not a
great library user myself but my
grandchildren availing themselves of
your services and also collected my book
bag which was a bit like getting a lucky
dip I understand they're very excited
about that they're aged five and eight I
also came upon your online storytime and
I'm still getting messages from Amy that
I should listen to reading but I haven't
actually done so yet but um I've also
passed it on to my daughter in
Queenstown who's got three little
toddlers because it seemed to me that
it's not just restricted to users within
this area so um you are traveling far
and wide with your products the other
thing I'd like to say is I have actually
downloaded your why me why McCreary
Library Act I haven't done anything what
you don't complete but I do have it
downloaded and that's something you
didn't mean today that as they're
getting publicized
I hadn't come across it previously so
anyhow I'm very pleased to move the
recommendation and like others have said
before if you pass how thanks onto your
staff that been very flexible and
counselor duty and myself deal with one
of your staff members and creative
community saying she's also doing very
well we're very pleased with her so
thank you very much thank you just love
this and I just think that's to have
your libraries up with your hair dry so
that's really well up the scale isn't it
so well done to you and thank you very
much for this very good report thank you
I just want to say I love your reports I
love I love it when they come into it
into my email box and I love it when you
come and tell us these stories because
you always walk away feeling good you
and your team have such a passion for
people in the fact that you have
actually bothered to change members and
data into human stories I mean that in
itself speaks volumes for you and your
team and I love what you guys have done
under under quite a lot of pressure
under lockdown from from home from your
own cars I mean it and you not only
pulled it off but you did it so well
that all around the country they want to
know what you did and how you did it
that is just phenomenal and also I I to
was tuned in and still getting
notifications about story times which I
loved and also I'm can't say that I've
picked up a lot of Samoan yet but I had
tuned into that too
so you guys just absolutely punch above
your weight and I again tip my hat to
you thank you just briefly just to Sur
concur with the comments made by
colleagues Paul you know what I think
about you and your team I come over
Ricky Lee and pass on my congratulations
to you I think you guys do awesome week
in through this period you've been
recognized through our community for
there and we had a meeting with a tricky
client last week and I was just amazed
how you tune that round someone who just
did not want to go online at all didn't
want to bar about when he came and to
the fact that he was quite open to their
conversation at the end it was a certain
generation of age in and it's the
challenge that you probably face every
day via but the way that you handle that
situation I was really impressed with
but like others pass on their thanks to
you and your team for the way in which
you've managed that period they're
really tricky on that Sunday as we were
coming into lockdown you may have people
and books going out the door but you
guys handled it so well and in the
volunteers working in behind as well
they've helped clean the books as
they've come back and it's been just a
combined effort to make sure that our
community has been malsu so
and looked after through that period so
thank you really thank you
i makes you be pleased you're big on
running again because we have brother
law that had just had radiation
treatment and and then it was a lockdown
and he's such an avid reader but he will
only read factual stuff so man we had to
go right through all our library and
pull out as much stuff as we could
possibly here giving the book blowed and
off he'd go down then he'd be back the
next week was he done they're looking
for more so I'm very pleased that he
pick into your library now not not
really I think it's all being said we're
very proud of the library service and
and our other departments the swimming
pool and also we've had bring with the
food forest so we've had a good
afternoon and I think you guys have all
done extremely well thank you
thank you um I do have a few slides so
my report gives an overview of the civil
defense welfare response and I'm aware
that you have already had a presentation
partway through that response so the
report gives a summary of what came
through the dashboard and identified
some needs that were addressed by the
team over the event it also includes an
overview of emerging issues so I feel
like the doom and gloom reports I'm
going to attempt to not be the doom and
gloom report today but particularly it
gives you a summary of the work that's
being done supported by the community
team through the community so far and
anticipating how we might address some
of the needs issues and opportunities
that come have come up over the coab
ravine and you will see attached to the
report a a copy of the second iteration
results from the community in social
sector report which was undertaken via
social services Waimakariri
and conducted and responds to some
planning that the community team did
just prior to the lockdown anticipating
that we would need to gather good
information from the community about the
issues that they were seeing in the
sector that they were seeing in the
community
so that report is now in its third
iteration it's being circulated again
and the plan is to regularly circulate
that report across the community so that
we can get a feel as to how the response
is going what the impact of the economic
downturn might be what the impact might
be on the mental health of their
community so I'll be giving you a
regular update snapshot of that what I
want to concentrate on today's is the
community's response
and really a strengths-based approach to
that so the first slide is to just give
you a heads up there to the University
of Auckland on Friday this produced this
hot off the press report protecting and
promoting it mental well-being beyond
Cove at 19 and the URL that I've got
there I won't play that in the interest
of time but there was an interview on
breakfast television on Friday which
highlighted the real impact that the
covert event is going to have on people
who aren't used to being in a state of
deep privation who aren't used to not
coping who aren't used to the social
sector and are probably going to be a
little bit lost at sea compared to the
usually vulnerable so I'll circulate
that with my bullet points this week and
me and you may be interested in having a
lot I'll also circulate the linked
report but if we can just perhaps
speed through I've only got a few slides
so the report in The Associated article
are a little bit doom and gloom and I
think in terms of the community's
response we what we really need to be
strengths-based we really need to
acknowledge the stresses that people are
experiencing to encourage them to
provide the supports that are necessary
point them to the information that they
need to get help point them to the
supports that they are and sipping
through and we want to be about
strengths and taking people from from a
point of real darkness and to hope and
possibility and I might use this um I
was talking to our new community
development person today and we were
talking about that while we want to
encourage people we really want to
empower them as well and I thought about
that I think this is aunt bee from The
Andy Griffith Show which some of you
might be old enough to remember but I
was I was kind of thinking about so so
for me those you know a really formative
thing was those great aunts who'd been
through the war and they've been through
the depression and they were the people
who if people were in a situation of
hardship they made the casserole and
they made the baking and they went
around and they they were a shoulder to
cry on but they worthy but they had some
answers they empowered people they had
that real onward and upward philosophy
and I've seen a bit of that in our
community over the last wee while and
have been really proud of the community
response I quite like this quote a
community is the mental and spiritual
condition of knowing that the place is
shared and that people who share the
place to fine in limit the possibilities
of each other's lives it is the
knowledge that people have of each other
their concern for each other they trust
in each other the freedom with which
they come and go among themselves and
why I like that quote is I think that
this is a community that really seeks to
know its people I think it's really easy
to get help for someone in this
community and a lot of the vulnerable
people that we have come across and the
covert 19 response and someone's known
them or someone's known who they can
link them up with and I think that's a
real strength of the community that we
live in so um oh golly they didn't
translate very well into this system the
reports that you have in front of you
details the work that's being considered
and carried out over recent weeks and I
was thinking of
we're at Fitz and I thought of Maslow's
hierarchy of needs which is pretty you
but good has nobody has heard of it I
crossed out the word needs because I
think we need to think of opportunities
and in each of the needs issues and
priorities that are detailed into the
report fits in line with one of those
Maslow's hierarchy of needs
so if we talk about food security and
Brent gave a very interesting and
informative presentation about food
forests food security is something
that's been identified throughout the
covert event we can't have food banks
running at capacity or beyond capacity
forever if we to create a real sense of
community we need to look at food more
broadly how do we get people growing
food how do we get people sharing
surplus how do we teach people to cook
with an expensive cuts of meat and
donated produce how do we create a food
community we the opportunity has been
identified to increase the amount of
skill and resource sharing so so trading
things like time banking beefing up the
capacity of the likes of time beings and
some of the community education like the
skill sharing that's associated with the
time-being program making sure that
people have good access to information
and that means that you're going to fill
those basic needs of people for the for
food for shelter to have the material
and physical needs meet the next one is
safety and it has been identified that
there is likely to be an increase in
mental health family violence and
dependency on substances and we're
already seeing that we're seeing a
significant increase in the number of
people seeking support for mental health
issues police report that family
violence is increased and that they're
only seeing the tip of the iceberg and
so we need to make sure that people
know how to have safe healthy
relationships that they know how to live
according to a healthy mental state of
mind we need to empower people with
skills and information so that their
well-being is supported if we think
about a sense of belonging you'll see
that we have identified there - people
who are newly affected through a loss of
employment or a change of financial
circumstances may not have a the same
access to opportunities that they used
to so looking at how we can provide
supports or funds talking to the likes
of rotary about how we can get people to
still be able to access the
opportunities that they have in the past
inclusion a sense of belonging is also
about making sure that you fit into the
society that's evolving and it was
really evident throughout the covert
event their digital isolation was a
really big thing for a lot of our older
people they couldn't easily pick up
information they couldn't easily connect
with people they couldn't easily get
access to the food and the services and
things that they needed social isolation
is another huge issue and it takes many
forms that can take that that takes the
form of you have a mental health issue
you lock yourself away nobody makes
contact with you you're an older person
you don't fit so inclusion is a really
big issue and I've included cultural
inclusion in you and that fits under
that sense of belonging self-esteem
likewise all of those things fit under
esteem as well but there is a real
opportunity to to connect people into
volunteering to ensure that they have
meaningful ways of reframing the sense
of self while they are in a situation of
albeit temporary unemployment and that's
been discussed in
various forums and of course
opportunities for ring education for
reemployment so I just thought it was
really interesting to to use their
illustration because if you are
fulfilling all of Maslow's hierarchy of
needs in your community you have strong
community and it's good to see that the
the initiatives that the community are
coming up with that line quite well with
it happy to take any questions related
to my report I'm sure we're all on board
with the potential for things to get
worse before they get better we're very
aware of that we also have great trust
in you and your umbrella of overarching
organizations to pull it all together
and coordinate the whole thing for our
people thank you very much for your
efforts questions Thanks thanks mr.
chair just thank you to sir for your
presentation just interested in there
currently what the level of demand is
and need in terms of the three things
I'm hearing mixed things so I just like
to know what you are we're off thank you
I think the big thing with food beings
is the food banks are a wee bit of a tip
of the iceberg thing in this community
as well because we originally had four
or five key food banks in the district
and at the moment we the food in
budgeting group doing a mapping across
the district because a lot of people
have just established new food banks so
we disturbed us to discovering new food
banks all the time some of the food
banks have had relatively steady demand
and I think that that's because
they have their sort of regular
clientele so Salvation Army would be a
really good example of that the demand
hasn't exponentially increased doesn't
you know it but some of the more sort of
community based food beings like Oxford
Community Trust have seen a significant
increase ky boy community support have
told us they've had and they've had a
hundred and fifty percent increase and
hope trusts have had a really
significant increase as well so I guess
it depends where they're getting their
clients from and if they have a social
service element to what they're doing
and they're linked in to a sort of
cohesive community the increase that
they're seeing is greater these are just
interested in what you know of any
government support for the food banks in
for wins for the newly unemployed are
you able to tell us a bit more about
that um yes I am button B regional teams
so there is currently a fund through
Ministry of Social Development and that
is specifically for support to resource
food banks and the food bank
collaborative that we've established
over covered here just put an
application into their fund now that
fund is designed to also be about
empowering food banks so it's got to be
sustainable so the the food surety or
food security programs that we are
discussing are going to be a part of
that fund and ye-yes is there's good
support for employment I'm not the
person to give you detail on there I do
have I do have that information but to
give it in this context as probably I'm
going to give you dodgy information so
but what I can do is send you a summary
from wee
can come so Tina Robinson's you eat some
detailed information and probably some
links because that that's kind of
evolving a little as well so sorry
second question as we we saw the drop in
volunteering when vulnerable people had
to stay home and has he still been
ongoing issues with volunteering
dropping given that a most of our
volunteers tend to be a little bit older
there has been something of a drop-off
and some of the food banks I think
people have some of the older volunteers
have decided not to come back partly
because they feel vulnerable some of
them have decided to get on with their
lives and they've been volunteering for
a long time and it's something that
they're considering and I know I've had
some conversations with student
volunteer army about how they might plug
some gifts ultimately but at the moment
they're coping quite well and I think
the collaborations helping a little bit
with that
Thank You Tessa for that
awesome report I have been privileged to
sit in your Welfare Committee meetings
throughout all of this and it has never
ceased to amaze me the the comprehensive
team of people that you've pulled
together to wrap around our community
and the care and empathy and compassion
that they have for the people that they
serve and I know you guys have run
yourself ragged and you know this is
this is a marathon not a sprint but I
just want to say I really appreciate the
work that you're doing and again we'd
like to continue to be able to help in
any way that I can and I just really
would like you to pass on to everybody
just how appreciative we are of
everything you do for our community
Thanks yes thanks very much Lisa
you are a network of community
organizations never ceases to amaze me
so this is a very good report as you say
you are slightly the gloomy spot at the
end of the afternoon but we do need to
know what's happening and it's good to
know that you've got your finger on the
pulse so thank you very much for your
report just echo the comments of
colleagues Tisa thanks for all your we
especially through the lockdown period I
know that you were highly valued and the
work that you were doing and tears the
civil defense work as well and in the
thinking that you've been giving in to
the psychosocial they speak Tazewell
which is important because it's the next
phase of where we're heading
I've reached out to you on a number of
occasions and always impressed with your
professionalism over that period
particularly with older vulnerable
people and it was particularly mentioned
to me when I've reached was talking with
grey Pierre in particular who were very
appreciative of yourself Medlen and
and the others and the team that were
making sure that people were connected
with in all our social service agencies
done a fantastic job and I guess that
we're all a period of saying thank you
because we really are very grateful to
our staff from the leadership that you
have provided through this time we're
very proud of you all you've done an
outstanding job to grant who's here - we
haven't specifically mentioned you
because we have need a report but ground
you and your green space team while
we're acknowledging as well pass on our
things there were some challenges over
that period of time and their paths and
reserves particularly our skateboard
parks as we know in another number of
other issues that came up through that
time so you all responded in a timely
way
címon with particularly with their
community facilities as well it's been a
big challenge but to all our staff press
you and your team we really think for
them appreciate of all the work that's
been done in will continue to be done
thank you - sir I just want to mention I
think that it's really good to see the
scripts the silver lining that's come
out of this is the collaboration between
all the food banks and how they are now
talking and sharing and so there's again
you get that disaster brings some really
good things out of it when people get
together and she and support each other
just also want to congratulate you from
the work done on helping support
fundraising for the groups and funding
applications with all the new funds that
are coming in and I go to the EC's W
meeting once a month they're meeting
monthly at the moment to try and support
more more often normally it's music a
month and the next meeting is on Monday
this coming Monday and I've been very
very impressed with the range of
agencies collaborating there so again
thank you for pulling all the strains
together anytime I get a welfare
question I don't know where to go I go
to Tisa nothing really more to
I forgot to say Nikki Carter is a rock
star
[Laughter]